incidentally I forgot to mention for the
people around the country we are coming
to you tonight from the beautiful
Dorothy Chandler Pavilion soon to become
the Pia Zadora pavilion depending on
course if the sale goes through to find
out who gets the next Oscar here are the
stunning Marion from Raiders of the Lost
Ark and the proud Coalhouse Walker from
ragtime Karen Allen and Howard E Rollins
jr.
both of our phones are for this award
all right the nominations for best
achievement and art direction are the
French Lieutenant's woman art direction
by Ashton Gordon set decoration by Anne
Malo art direction by Tammy Larson set
direction by Jim Berkey art direction by
John Grey's mark Patrizia van
brandenstein an Anthony reading set
decoration by George - Tito jr. George
de Tita senior and Peter Howard Raiders
of the Lost Ark art direction by set
direction by Michael Ford Reds art
direction by widget Civic set
regulations by Michael Sartain Karen the
world awaits the winners are norman
Reynolds and
I was dreading the moment of actually
having to say something but it's it's
arrived and I'd like to thank my art
department who aren't here tonight and
the construction people who backed me
100% and also George Lucas for actually
suggesting to Steven that I did the
picture and even more so Steven for
actually agreeing to that suggestion and
thank you very much everybody who made
it possible for this to happen thank you